you know you make marks in a book and
like you'd think it would help but it
does ok here we go
[Music]
this book is really cool it's this super
well researched account of Robert Falcon
Scott it's time and Antarctic but from
the perspective of the photographs he
took hi i'm coleman i make culture and
history videos here at bucks and i'm
currently working on a series called
darkroom which is about photography i
linked the first episode in the
description of this video and if you
haven't seen it yet you might want to
watch that first or else all this isn't
really gonna make a lot of sense
anyway scott was really serious about
finding diverse ways to conduct and
document scientific work antarctica and
of the many things he was doing while he
was down there learning photography was
one of them shooting photos over a
century ago was a much more involved
process than it is today but scott had
some pretty good teachers namely this
guy
herbert Ponting he was the official
photographer from the expedition and he
taught scott how to use a camera I
really loved this exchange between
Ponting and Scott because it gives you a
really good idea of how hard I was to
take a photo back then and how eager
Scott was to learn okay so this is
prompting
talking to Scott are you quite sure you
did everything correctly my dear fellow
I'm absolutely certain I did I'm sure I
made no mistake did you put in the plate
holder yes
did you draw the slide yes did you set
the shutter yes did you release the
shutter yes you take the cap off the
lens yes then he would rub his head in
that way he had an admit no good heavens
I forgot I could have sworn I had
forgotten nothing Scott within restock
his kit and try again and again and he
actually got pretty good at it
moniece sorry I forgot this was here so
the other person helping him was this
guy Edward Wilson he was one of Scott's
best friends and the sketch artist who
would go on with him to the South Pole
and died in the tent on the way back
this photo is really interesting for a
couple of reasons one it shows how good
of a grasp on composition Scott was
developing during the expedition
composition in particular was the thing
that Wilson who you can see sketching
right here was teaching Scott now
compared Scott's landscape with Wilson's
sketch which you can see here it's spot
on and that's because pencil sketch
had for centuries been the method of
recording geography and things like
animal and plant life during expeditions
like this one so it's pretty cool to see
one of the last great expeditionary
sketch artists doing his work while a
new technology behind him does the same
job without flaw in an instant and one
last thing Scott was really getting into
all that is hard to look at this is
snippets Nobby Michael and Jimmy Pig
guys okay
action sequences this is something Scott
was experimenting with capturing motion
and kinetic moments rather than just
portraits and landscapes like most of
the people learning photography at the
time we're doing they're blurry and not
very well composed which is why most
people weren't even trying to do this
with photography but Scott was and
that's pretty cool anyway keep an eye
out for new dark room episodes I swear
they're not all gonna be total bummers
thanks for watching and see you guys
soon